будинку немає городу немає нічого немає
і бабця виходить несе нам якусь банку
яка вціліла огірків закатаних тут плаче
багато тому що ще не відійшли ще все
настільки свіже що вони не сплять і вони
багато плачуть Тобто вона ось 20 хвилин
надо помирала а тут вона вже роздає
рушники які вона сама вишивала абсолютно
незнайомим людям зараз останні наші
візит на Харківщині там не було просто
на дорозі де їхала наша машина є лікар я
повинна бути там
Наталія Лелюх практикуюча
лікарка-гінеколог блогерка письменниця А
тепер волонтерка з 24 лютого Наталія
їздить звільненими українськими
територіями і надаємо медичну допомогу
місцевому населенню Вітаю Наталія дякую
що знайшли час з нами поговорити перше
питання Чому з 24 лютого ви вирішили І
обрали саме такий вид волонтерства
їздити декупованими територіями адже ви
могли би залишитись в Києві також
надавати медичну допомогу як тільки
почалися з'являтися перші
деокуповані населені пункти в Київській
області тата була
тато В мене вона поліцейська вони
виїхали першими поліцейськими екіпажами
по Київщині і приїхавши вона перший раз
вона поїхала без мене приїхала сказала
Наташа завтра їдемо разом тому що там
дуже багато людей які потребують
допомоги потім Ми зрозуміли що в
принципі в такій великій міста як
гостомельбуча Ірпінь достатньо швидко
приїде медицина яка допоможе їм а в
маленьке містечко є села не
люди доїжджають дуже рідко просто не
доїжджають ні в нас було таке якби
внутрішнє завдання проїхати по маленьким
всім селищам Які були або на лінії
фронту або були окуповані а наскільки це
небезпечно Чи ви там моніторите перед
тим як ви їдете кудись Ну звичайно ми
моніторимось для цього у нас якраз і
поліція нашої яка нам дуже допомагає по
суті ми є таким якби
не Тож ми є підрозділом да Тобто я не є
поліцейською але тата поліцейський в
принципі це підрозділ патрульної поліції
це батальйон Тор підрозділ Софія
безпосередньо в якому якби ми ну я
нечислююсь тому що я є цивільним лікарем
але ми і вони мають інформацію про
безпечність плюс з нами завжди їздять
люди які несуть на собі функції охорони
і безпеки нашої вони перевіряють якщо ми
тобто в будинки ми заходимо не першим
спочатку віддає хтось він перевіряє
можливість щоб не було ніяких
обслугованих ситуацій на мій не дати
звичайно тільки там де тільки-тільки
відбулася деокупація але інколи от зараз
останні наш візит на Харківщині там міни
були просто на дорозі де їхали наша
машина і це тоже тобто все ж таки зору
безпеки да е-е цей війна і ми не можемо
бути абсолютно в безпеці де б ми не
знаходилися і прилетіти може куди
завгодно якщо ми говоримо про ракетні
обстріли але наші поїздки ну по Київщині
зараз вже звичайно менш небезпечні хоча
також перші виїзди були дуже
небезпечними з цієї точки зору А от Ми
були у Василенко Олена Харківщині ми
приїхали А за годину до цього там були
якраз розмінування місцеві мешканець
пішов показувати мінера в саперам
показувати де знаходяться міни і всі
троє підірвалися і всі насмерть ну тобто
це було От просто за годину як ми туди
приїхали повертаючись до вашої історії
розумію що вам тата сказала що є така
потреба Але чому ми тому що я лікар тому
що ну знаєте в мене була така історія я
ж лікар майдану тому відповідно
достатньо давно волонтерстві Тобто це не
от відбулося 24 це відбулося ще в 14-му
році і
я просто не завжди запам'ятала день 21
Ні до 20-го напевно лютого на Майдані
коли був це другий день розстріл я була
чергувала там на Майдані коли горів
Будинок Профспілок і на другий день на
День коли ніч коли штурмували
європейський дом
але коли от був цей розстріл
безпосередньо небесної Небесної Сотні
яка була 20-го я в цей день чергувала на
роботі і я сиділа в мене стрім постійно
йшов і там постійно в стрімі треба
лікаря Треба лікаря Треба лікаря А я
сиджу на роботі і розумію що я тут я
лікар я а я повинна бути там і оця от
історія
моєї необхідності не тут а там напевно
вона зіграла свою роль в моєму рішенні
ви днями повернулися з Харківщини з
окупованих та до окупованих міст Яке
ваше зараз найсильніше Враження з тієї
поїздки знаєте я це статую нас досить
часто про це питають ваше там
найти така історія
най-най-най-най-най враження
не може бути най-най-най тому що
воно все не можна як не можна міряти
любов Да вона не може бути більше не
може бути менша вона або є її немає так
само і тут коли ти бачиш біль коли ти
бачиш якусь людську трагедію коли ти
бачиш війну то вона ну не може жахати
щось менше не може жахати щось більше
може ти просто або в постійній броні
внутрішній і намагаєшся не включатися в
цій історії тої машини якщо ти просто
зітрешся в нуль або ти просто реагуєш на
кожну і тоді це досить боляче насправді
ми так Ну ми все одно як звичайно що ми
не ходимо холодними роботами Да ми все
одно включаємося Але нас більше з точки
зору ключки
роблять такі якісь речі коли там
повністю от будинку немає городу немає
нічого немає і бабця виходить несе нам
якусь банку яка вціліла огірків
закатаних і несе нам цю банку і каже
дітки треба їсти бо ви такі худенький
голодні у неї нічого немає вона нам цю
банку огірків несе отут ми да Отут в нас
може прибрати і ми можемо ридати просто
цілодобово після такої історії і знаєте
що дивує от мене страшенно дивує що
харківщина абсолютно україномовна от вся
маленька харківщина маленькі села на
Харківщині це
95% людей чисто україномовних вибираєте
Жіночі історії ми говоримо і збираємо і
не тільки з жінками Ну бо воно ну так
говоримо з чоловіками говоримо з дітьми
Ми говоримо багато є дуже сумні історії
Я дуже болючі історії є історії
такого героїзму просто такого
простого людського героїзму коли
наприклад жінка
12 км в березні по бездоріжжю під
обстрілами на двох тачках вивозила одна
одній тачці вона тягнула свого чоловіка
після опера речі які не міг ходити в
кого була кровотеча і там купа всього і
свою свекруху якої після інсульту яка
тоже не може ходити і от вона одну тачку
пропихала Потім ну зупинялась накривала
одеялом Пішла за другою тачкою тягнули
так 12 кілометрів 2,5 доби вона їх
вивозила з окупованої території до
якоїсь лікарні на уже Ну на території
України Вона проходила через блок-пости
вона плакала вона показувала що ось у
мене двоє хворих яких Треба довести і це
не просто подвиг це ну я не знаю це те
на що треба молитися що люди є які
можуть собі то що ти дозволити бути
людьми і це просто Неймовірні історії і
їх дуже багато насправді от саме
історіями є щось таке що ви нове там
зрозуміли про себе по-перше а по-друге
про українців можливо Чи це все було щоб
ви знали про людей
щось нове напевно ні я більше розумію що
українці це
неймовірні люди це люди з офігенним
почуттям гумору
це люди в більшості своїй настільки
відкриті щирі тоже показової історії Ми
приїхали в одне село на Київщині там три
хати може залишилося цілими атак майже
немає села маленькі дуже маленькі це
Хуторок такий назвемо і туди привезли
жінку з Бучі її Ну вона вже похилого
віку її вивезли з Буча тут вона
просиділа в погребі тому що її будинок
також згорів знову все весело і ми коли
приїхали там ГОСТ там запалення легень
Там пліврієте ми її там туди я і
подивилася дала ліки вколола їй трошки
попустили вона почала дихати температура
почала спадати і тільки їй стало там
через там хвилин 20 пакет там ще малих
дітей дивилися їй стає краще вони стоять
дихати і вона каже так Дівчата я вообще
вишиваю і в мене отут я там і доньки Він
каже Так доньки несіть скриню значить
принесли скриню Отак дівчата Вибирайте
собі от будь-яку вишиванку яка там
лежить мені кажете ну лише не
ми офіційно незаміжні і вони мене каже
ото в собі по рушнику І ото по рушнику
візьмете от ото точно Ви йдете заміж от
це ми десь Тобто вона ось 20 хвилин
назад помирала а тут вона вже роздає
рушники які вона сама вишивала абсолютно
незнайомим людям і от це для мене про
українців і це настільки прямото що я
прям захоплююсь нашою нашими людьми
нашою нацією нашої держави от якраз в
контексті дівчата жінок а чи ви думаєте
що ця війна якось вплинула на українські
жіноцтво
Я б не розділяла жінок і чоловіків я не
хотіла цього тому що Це вплинуло взагалі
на всіх на дітей на дорослих на людей
похилого віку це на всіх вплинуло
по-різному тому жінки звичайно і на
рівні просто у жінок досить багато
фізіології
зачеплено на психологічному стані тому
що для нас
репродукція да тобто наша Жіноча статева
система репродуктивна Вона досить сильно
залежить від того що відбувається
навколо жінки і якщо жінка знаходиться в
стані хронічного або остео стресу
репродукція як процес енергозатратний і
довготривалий відключається тому що не
до цього вижити і частіше є проблеми
гінекологічні у жінок під час війни я
про це багато розповідаю і розповідаю
вже на чому клубі в себе на сторінці
тому да жінки змінилися вони змінилися
саме тому що вони змінилися а тому що це
жіноча фі Я зараз ні в якому разі не
зменшую важливі жінки в світі тому що я
гінеколог Я взагалі я взагалі їх обожнюю
це моя робота і моє життя Але це мені
здається просто не відгадати А які стан
взагалі з медициною на місцях в селах ну
найчастіше проблема Ми більше все ж таки
по селам Це або повністю відсутня
амбулаторія Тобто вона ну або розломлена
або розтрощена або її просто повністю
розікрали Тобто там просто нічого немає
але інша проблема немає лікарів лікарі
або виїхали або
не працюють або загинули ну тобто різні
є історії і основна проблема - це
відсутність спеціалістів на місцях от
хатах Як ви зустрічають місцеве
населення те буде найчастіше ну
найчастіше добре зустрічаю Звичайно 90%,
що це ну зараз просто
різної емоційний настрій і От наприклад
на Харківщині останні дві поїздки тобто
Тиждень тому була перший раз Балаклея а
потім зараз Балаклія Ну і села навколо
неї е-е і
Ізюм і також села навколо ізюму тут
плачуть багато тому що ще не відійшли ще
все настільки свіже що вони не сплять і
вони багато плачуть тобто спочатку тобі
треба прочекати Поки людина тобі виплаче
там перші там 5 хвилин 10 хвилин вона
повинна виплакатись а потім далі вона
вже з тобою спілкується як з лікарем як
з людиною і тому перша емоційна реакція
- це сльози можуть бути лише за радості
але це все одно сльози і вона спочатку
плаче а потім далі ти з ним спілкуєшся
тому от треба бути готовим до великої
кількості сліз тобто перша допомога яку
ви надаєте по суті це психологічна
допомога вислухати просто вислухати
просто обійняти Просто потримати якщо
людина дозволяє теж Ми не ліземо
обніматися з усіма нам треба зрозуміти
відстань і дистанцію людини і якщо
людина прям хоче щоб її обняли да да
будь ласочка ми задоволенням потримаємо
за руку обнімемо ви вислухаєте всі ці
історії як ви потім приїжджаєте додому
відновлювати напевно
відпочинком для мене є десь посидіти в
безпечному місці на природі подивитися
послухати пташок подивитися на там на
росу там я не знаю просто помовчати
подумати Ну і звичайно знаєте як кажуть
зміна роботи - це також відпочинок да
зміна виду діяльності я приїжджаю От ми
на три дні прийому в клініці Я три дні
спілкуюся з моїми вагітними Я глажу
животики мені мені
розповідають Хто де Яке грудне
вигодовування що відбувається ну тобто я
працюю як гінеколог і це насправді не
виснажує а навпаки тобто так ну якби
балансує да ту роботу і цю роботу І от
зміна цієї діяльності це дуже-дуже
приємна історія у ваших поїздах Що для
вас найважче знаєте що найважче от я щас
прям Відверто з таку скажу Мені важко
якщо я розумію що я цій людині Нічим не
можу допомогти і ця людина потребує
якоїсь допомоги А я її не маю Не маю
конкурсу немає ліків немає ще чогось це
страшенного завжди подразнює мене і
приїжджаючи назад я намагаюся зрозуміти
як при наступній такій історії що мені
треба мені треба замовити якісь ліки
мені треба замовити якусь якийсь апарат
мені треба замовити якісь розхідники
тобто чого мені не вистачило І коли ти
кажеш людині Ні в мене цього немає або у
нас цього немає або ми не надаємо таку
допомогу оце напевно така річ яка мене
дуже вибиває тому що мені здається що в
мене вже стільки цих ліків або там один
просто Дайте мені дві коробочки Ти
розумієш що в тебе всього три в тебе
зараз їх попросять іще хтось ти кажеш ні
може дати тільки одну коробочку І от
этого ні
от його складно говорити Я розумію що у
вас класна команда і розумієш Ви
відчуваєте місію в тому що ви робите але
водночас ми всі хто читає особливо в
вашій історію і розумієш що це дуже
важко ви ще от розраховуєте Скільки вас
вистачить на те щоб їздити
допомагати поки будуть нам донатити поки
нам буде за що купувати ліки тому що ми
в більшості випадків ми самі купуємо Да
те що нам приходить на фонд ми не
отримуємо якусь прям гуманітарну
допомогу Да ми про самі ми самі
вишукуємо потреби Самі їх покривають
поки буде можливість це робити я думаю
що ми будемо це робити І дуже хочеться
щоб не було потреби в цьому цього
хочеться всім але ну ставте про себе
Реально все знову ж таки ми розуміємо що
нас Треба щоб потреба в нас буде ще
довго Нам потрібні будемо І після
перемоги тому що треба відновлювати
інфраструктуру треба відновлювати наші
будинки треба відновлювати
медичну допомогу не просто відновлювати
треба міняти з урахуванням того досвіду
якими отримали і я думаю що наша
допомога
потрібна буде ще достатньо довго то
після на початку війни в 14-му році
з'явилися ради волонтерів різних або це
при міністерствах були ради волонтерів
або ради ну тобто були якісь
волонтерські організації які існують на
сьогоднішній день з 14-го року вони є і
в них вистачило наснаги до
сьогоднішнього дня і вистачить іще
десятки років тому що ну десятки років
це так склалось не тому що війна буде
тривати все ж таки дуже ми всі хотіли би
щоб це було швидше але мається на увазі
що Оскільки ми будемо потрібні тільки ми
будемо існувати Дуже дякую вам за
розмову і за вашу роботу